[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM MCVEETY: Welcome.
Today you'll be hearing about
Nest's use of Cloud Platform
to prototype massive
scale services
and using a philosophy
I affectionately refer
to as launching and iterating.
So I'm Sam McVeety.
I'm the tech lead
of Cloud Dataflow.
And I'm really thrilled to be
joined today by Kevin and Peter
from Nest.
And most of the
talk today is going
to be their show, because we
just built the infrastructure.
They did all the hard work.
So I'll give most
of the time to them.
But before then, by
way of an introduction,
I'll talk briefly about
what launching and iterating
looks like on Google's cloud.
And then they'll go into
a little bit more depth
on what specifically
Nest is doing
and how they're
building their services.
So launching and iterating--
one of the things I really
love about working at Google
is this idea that
you can take an idea
and you can prototype it.
You can see what works, what
doesn't, tweak it, fail fast,
succeed quickly if you're lucky.
But you can do that.
And you can quickly
make progress that way.
And you're going to see how
the Nest folks did that.
And what I love
about the cloud is
that it brings this
capability to everyone.
It's not something that
is locked in at Google.
It is something that anybody
that uses Google Cloud
has access to.
So you sort of take one thing
away from this presentation,
it's going to be--
I hope it's this quote.
One engineer, no systems
background, and three days.
And this isn't an outlier.
This is how you can quickly use
the cloud to validate ideas,
to move forward, make
progress, succeed quickly.
For example, we had a hackathon
recently on the Dataflow team.
And this is what it looked like
where, in a matter of days,
people were building
things on infrastructure
and turning those ideas
into a reality, to say, hey,
this is something we want to run
with or eh, maybe not so good.
So in making these
things a reality,
let's talk briefly about some
of the tech that's available.
So this first one
is Google BigQuery.
So this is your fast,
economical data warehouse
for large scale analytics.
And you can really throw
all your data in here.
You don't have to worry
about indices or sharding.
You just send all
your data to BigQuery.
You can you use
SQL, standard SQL,
to ask questions about the data.
And you don't have to know
what those questions look
like upfront.
You're not doing any
sort of preoptimization.
So if it turns out that you're
asking the wrong questions
or you didn't know
what questions you
were going to ask, it's
there to iterate on.
And there's no backtracking,
no repartitioning necessary.
Now to get the data
there in the first place,
you need something
like App Engine.
So this allows you to build
a scalable web application
quickly on any of the languages
that Google's infrastructure
supports.
You can stand up
a service simply,
throw up some endpoints.
And if we're talking about
devices that you just
want to send simple REST calls
from, like for the Nest folks,
this is a great way
for them to phone home,
send telemetry data quickly.
And then you can
analyze that offline.
Now if you want something
a little more full
featured than SQL, that's were
something like Cloud Dataflow
comes in.
So using the Apache Beam
model, Cloud Dataflow
provides a way to
write your code
and run it in batch
or streaming mode.
So upfront, you don't know
if you care about latency.
You can iterate on your code
while it's in batch mode.
And then if latency turns out
to be something you care about,
you can run it in a
stream processing fashion.
Also you don't have to
worry about provisioning.
It's a managed service.
It has autoscaling.
So you're not worrying
about replicas upfront.
You just say, hey,
here's my code.
I want to run it.
I want to see how it works.
And then sort of stepping
back a level, in general,
you don't even have
to know which cloud do
you want to run on, at first.
You want to prototype
on Google's cloud.
Our commitment to
open source means
that if it turns out
the investment isn't
the right place, you can move,
because you're not locked in.
So with BigQuery
for example, you
have standards SQL
support where you can
run those queries elsewhere.
For App Engine, you
can take your container
and run it on Kubernetes.
And for Dataflow, you have
this engine portability by Beam
where you can run that
on the Dataflow runner.
You can run that
on Spark, anything
that implements the standard.
So altogether, this
provides this ability
to launch and iterate.
You don't have to answer all
these questions, provisioning
all these things upfront.
You just have to have an idea.
And you can validate
that idea quickly
without letting all these
details get in the way.
So, thank you again
for coming, and let
me introduce Kevin from Nest.
KEVIN PETERSON: Thanks Sam.
So I want to start here
just by introducing
Nest and a little bit
about what our mission is
and what we're
trying to accomplish
and how we're going to
use the GCP infrastructure
that Sam's team has worked on.
So at Nest, our
mission is to create
a home that takes care
of the people inside it
and the world around it.
And we accomplish this mission
via the different products
that we have.
So we take unloved
products in homes
and try to reinvent them
and make them smarter,
make them do more for you.
So we started with the
Learning Thermostat,
followed that up with the
smoke and CO alarm, and then
an indoor and outdoor camera.
But more than just
the products, we
have the app that's behind
it that lets you actually
interface with your
devices and your home,
and then that service which
sort of backs everything up.
So Nest is sort of often
considered a hardware company,
but are truly much more
than that because the apps
and the services that
are behind everything
are really the important bits.
So I'm part of the
algorithms team at Nest,
and I'm going to introduce
a little bit what
my team is responsible for.
So we are the team that sort
of takes the data from--
takes our data and tries to
make intelligent features
for your devices.
And so we have a
principal at Nest
that any data that's
measured by our device
should return value to
you, the user of it.
And we do this via features
like Home/Away Assist and auto
schedule.
We're trying to make sure
that when you're not home
or when you don't want your
home to be heating or cooling
itself, we can turn off
your AC or your heating
and make sure that
you save energy.
We also use our sensors to build
thermal models of the home.
And this lets us offer
features like Time-to-Temp,
so that when you change the
temperature of your home,
we tell you how long it's
going to take to get there
so you know, maybe you're
leaving in an hour,
you don't need to turn
it to a temperature
that it's not going to
reach for two hours.
Rush Hour Rewards is a
partnership with energy
services and energy programs.
This lets us actually
precool your home
before maybe a time
of day when energy's
going to be very expensive.
And this will let you save
money plus let the energy
companies avoid these
really high peak loads that
can cause rolling blackouts.
Steam Check and Sunblock
are both features
that fuse multiple
sensors on the device
to make the device
smarter and do more.
So with Steam Check, we
can detect the difference
between steam and smoke
and actually build
a smoke alarm that
is less annoying, not
going to go off at
7:00 in the morning
when you get on the
shower, wake the kids up.
And then with Sunblock,
we can detect,
is the temperature in the
home actually going up,
or is it just the sun has
come through the window now
and is hitting the
thermostat and we
see a rise in temperature,
but your home is still
the same temperature
and we don't need
to waste energy cooling it.
So, my team is
responsible for taking
these features all the way
from the very beginning,
from maybe an idea, a sheet
of paper in your lab notebook,
through the production scale.
And so what I want
to talk about today
is how we use GCP to
really take these concepts
from the notebook
and show that they're
feasible and worth investing in.
So I'm sort of at this
very beginning stage.
We're still trying to find
out, is this possible?
Is it something we can do?
And so we don't want to invest
a ton of the company's resources
on an idea that we haven't
even shown is doable yet.
And so the first thing we need
to do is build a prototype
and collect data.
And so at this scale,
or at this stage,
we're sort of sitting at a
lab bench, maybe have a sensor
that we've ordered
from the manufacturer,
or trying to figure
out, can we measure
the things we need to measure?
And we found that each engineer
had a very different method
that they like to run
their experiments,
that they like to store
and organize their data.
Some people would use
Google Spreadsheet
to keep track of all the
experiments they're running.
Other people would actually
embed the different parameters
in the filename itself so
they could parse it out later.
And this just
didn't really scale.
We weren't able to
communicate very well what
each different
engineer was doing.
And it was hard
to make that data
available to the people
that needed to see to make
their decisions early on.
And so we were sort of
faced with this problem of,
how do we collect and label
data in a scalable way?
And so we need to take data
that's sitting on sensors,
probably plugged into a
laptop, maybe a Raspberry
Pi or something like that, and
get it to the engineers that
are going to use it.
And because this
is GCP Next, you
can probably guess how I'm
going to go about this.
So, we want to
build an App Engine
project to take that data,
put it in a few data stores,
and then feed it back
to the engineers.
And so we built a
service an App Engine
that allows ingest
and data querying.
We used Cloud Storage, which
is Google's object store,
to store the blobs
of sensor data.
So this is temperature
samples, humidity, smoke,
things like that that are
really just CSVs or JSON blobs.
And then the important bit
here is using Cloud Datastore
as a metadata service.
And so here we can
actually label our data
in a sort of scalable way, a way
that everybody can understand,
and we can query that
to get the data back.
So you can say, give me
all the experiments that
were run at room temperature.
Give me all the experiments that
were run at 50 degrees C. So
we can make sure that as
we develop our products,
we know exactly how
they're working.
And the first thing we found
in building the service
is that people wanted to use it.
And so now we have
the same data being
used by the hardware engineers
to validate their sensors.
We have the same data being
used by our embedded team
as they're sort of trying
to prototype and take
these algorithms and
put them on the devices.
And what's more is this data was
immediately available to them.
So as soon as people collect
the data in the lab, now
they can immediately query it
sitting at their desk running
simulations, things like that.
And then we can scale
it up even further
and plug this directly into
our development infrastructure
and our build system.
So now as we start implementing
the algorithms on the device,
we can pull that
data down into the
build system every time
we have a new build
and make sure the
algorithm is still doing
what we expect it to be doing.
And this is really
powerful for us,
because now we can do
regression testing.
We can make sure that as
we develop new features,
we don't go backwards on
any of our other features.
And finally, we can take
that output from our
build system and actually feed
it back into the metadata.
So now we have tags on all of
our data showing which builds
were successful,
which builds weren't.
We can start exporting
this data into BigQuery
and really doing
analytics on it.
So we can find out,
is there a trend?
Is there a pattern?
Is there maybe a
particular algorithm
that has trouble at very
high temperatures or very
low temperatures?
If there's a particular
data set that
had a bunch of events
all happening at once,
we can see that and
say, oh, maybe we
have a timing problem
on the prototype
that we're working
on that we need
to dig into and make sure that
our software is addressing
that.
And this sort of all can work
because we have a common data
set that's shared by
everybody and we know what
we're trying to experiment on.
And so this lets us
build better algorithms
because we have better data.
And more importantly, we
get to spend more time
on collecting the data and
less on all of the record
keeping, because
the service handles
the record keeping for us.
And as I mentioned
earlier, this whole service
took one engineer that
didn't have any service
experience at all--
the algorithms team is
mathematicians, roboticists,
machine learning experts.
It doesn't cover any systems
or services engineers.
And it was able to be built
over a three day period, which
is really powerful.
So, now we're at the
point where we've
sort of proven the hardware.
We understand that our
sensors can collect
the right information
and we can sort of
implement the algorithm.
But algorithms don't
exist in a vacuum.
It's actually very important
that we interact with the user
during algorithms.
So we want to understand
how a user is going
to use the different
features on the device
and how they're going
to be affected by it.
And so we need another
service for this
to actually explore
these different features.
And so we have our Nest cloud,
which I've sort of shown here.
That sort of interfaces between
your phone or your laptop
and all the different smart
devices that you might have.
But at this sort of phase
of the product development,
we're still very small.
We're still sort of
trying to figure out
how this feature really works.
And so what we actually
want is a small service,
something that we can
iterate on really quickly.
We can deploy maybe once every
10 minutes, deploy every hour,
things like that.
And we're just not
ready to integrate it
with our production app
and our production service
and go through all of the
release processes that
are needed there.
And we want to make our
algorithms engineers directly
responsible for the
logic and implementation,
so that if they find
something that's not working,
they can immediately
address it and fix it.
And so again, we can build a
simple real time service in GCP
to do this.
So we'll start with App
Engine as our REST API
that lets both the devices and
the apps communicate together.
We'll feed that through
some algorithm logic
to implement whatever
feature we're
looking to implement,
and then store
the state of the device
in Cloud Datastore.
This lets us use Cloud Datastore
as sort of the backing store
that either an app
or a device can query
to figure out what's going on.
So you might imagine storing
temperature data or something
like that.
And again, we can
export this to BigQuery
to let us do analytics on
how a user is interacting
with the device.
So we can store a record of
did the temperature get changed
by the app or by the
device, and which
direction is things flowing?
Do people prefer
to use the device
to change the temperature or
do they prefer to use the app
to change its temperature?
And we're fortunate
at Nest to have
a very active internal test
group so we can actually
get quite a good set
of data from just
all of our internal employees
trying things out for us.
So I want to walk through just
a little bit of how simple this
actually is to build by
showing a bit of code here.
So the first thing we wanted was
real time state communication.
So we want the apps
and the devices
to communicate together.
And this we'll do
with App Engine,
and specifically in Python
here with using the web
app to web framework.
And so we just need
two functions here,
a get function and
a post function
so that we can update the
state and we can fetch it back.
And then we use Cloud Datastore
to actually store the data,
sort of do all the
heavy lifting for us.
And the APIs that
Google Cloud provides
are really simple here.
You can see in the
get function, we just
create a key using the
device ID and fetch the data
and write it back out to
whoever called that function.
And then for sort of
similarly in reverse,
we write the data directly
into Cloud Datastore.
Cloud Datastore is NoSQL, so
we can add or remove fields
as we need.
And it's very easy
to update this.
And it really is just
these 10 lines of code
that let us do this.
And so the next step we want is
using BigQuery for analytics.
This lets us sort of track
how things change over time.
And the BigQuery
streaming API lets
us really quickly send
data over to BigQuery
and make it
immediately available.
So now we can very quickly sort
of look at things in real time
and don't have to wait to do
our analytics the day after.
We can iterate much faster,
as Sam was talking about.
And again, because all of
this is sort of an integrated
part of GCP, it's very quick.
Getting credentials
for authentication
is just a couple of
lines at the top.
That means that we
don't have to worry
about implementing our own
authentication mechanism
or anything like that.
And we can be guaranteed
that it's a secure system.
We can know that only this App
Engine application is allowed
to talk to this BigQuery
table to send data over to it,
and not worry about
configuring it ourselves.
And then again at
the bottom, it's
just a very simple
API call using
the libraries BigQuery
provides to send data over
to that service.
And then finally we
can use this service
to explore higher level logic.
So instead of just
persisting and logging state,
we can actually implement
this complex logic.
And so here I've sort of
put a function in the middle
that I've labeled
apply_logic, which
sort of sounds like cheating.
But it really isn't because
all it is a Python function.
And that's the magic is
that we don't have to do
a whole lot of extra work.
We just write a
Python function that
takes some existing
state and new state,
and does some arithmetic or
does some logic and figures
out what we want to do.
And this lets us
iterate, again, very,
very quickly, so that if we
want to try something out,
we don't have to go through
the process of creating a build
for the device, validating
that that build's
not going to break
the device, and then
doing a rolling software
update on our test devices.
We can actually
just very quickly
change something in the service,
redeploy, see how it's going,
and keep doing that
over and over until we
have something that works well.
There are a bunch of
other useful things
that are just sort
of hidden away
in App Engine that
make developing pretty
easy or pretty remarkable.
And one of these is
the deferred library
that I've highlighted here.
So this lets you schedule
things to happen later,
by taking advantage of
the App Engine task queue.
And so here I'm deferring
the BigQuery insert,
because that can sometimes
be an operation that maybe
takes a little bit of time.
And so we don't want to
put that in the real time
loop of devices fetching state.
And so we just do that
sort of asynchronously.
And then additionally,
I've written
this to schedule a callback.
So in 300 seconds, that
callback function will execute.
And maybe we can make
a different decision
that we made up
front, or reconsider
the decision we made initially.
And that again is a
very powerful thing
to be able to do.
And it's even more
powerful that we can do it
with a single line of code.
And all of this sort
of has the function
of making services easy for us.
So everything just
sort of scales.
Datastore, BigQuery, App
Engine are all things
that just scale by
default. And so we
don't have to worry when our
little 10 devices that we were
testing on all of a sudden
becomes the whole company
trying out our product.
You never want to
be in that situation
where you have to tell
someone, oh, I just
built this on my desktop and I
can't let anybody else use it.
Now we can make sure that
everything that we're building,
anybody in the company that
needs to use it can use it.
We don't have to spend
any time managing VMs.
Again, not a services engineer,
not a systems engineer.
I don't want to make sure that
I've closed all the right ports
on some machine somewhere.
Because App Engine's
the interface,
it's sort of secure by
default. And the built in OAuth
authentication lets us use
all of the Google services
and make sure that those
services are secure
and that the only data that--
the data can only
be accessed by us.
And really we get to focus on
the logic of the applications,
which are the bits
we're good at,
and let Google focus on
the mechanics, which is
the bits they're very good at.
And then from there, I'm
going to turn it over
to Peter who's going to tell you
about how we scale all this out
and monitor it in production.
PETER GRABOWSKI: So hi, my
name is Peter Grabowski.
I'm the tech lead and manager
of the data integration
team at Nest.
I wanted to start off by saying
thank you to Sam for giving us
a great overview of the
managed technologies
available within
Google, and a thank
you to Kevin for a
great walkthrough of how
his team develops and
prototypes algorithms at Nest.
So I'd like to talk to you today
a little bit about how we think
about scaling out those
algorithms, the systems that
make them scale, and also
once they have been deployed,
how we monitor them and
make sure they do what
we think that they're doing.
So this is our architecture.
To get started, I'd like
to give a quick tour
through our architecture.
This won't be the focal
point of the talk,
but it will come in handy and
provide some useful context
for later in our discussion.
One of the things I wanted
to highlight right away
is that, as Sam mentioned,
we've got both open source
and managed technologies here.
And being able to
co-locate those gracefully
within the same environment
was a major draw for using GCP.
So you can see some
managed technologies
that Sam talked about.
You've got Dataflow
and BigQuery.
You can also see some
open source technologies
that we use, like Apache Storm,
Apache Kafka, and Hadoop HDFS.
So our system begins,
like many others,
with the data logging service.
We've got many devices
out in the field.
We've got cameras.
We've got smoke detectors.
We've got thermostats.
They're all sending
data up to the service.
They're sending it up
in different formats.
in different sizes.
They're sending it up
in different shapes.
No matter what size
or shape they're
sending it up in, it's received
by the data logging service.
This sits out in front
of our architecture,
and it's responsible
for three things.
So it's designed to be very
purposely straightforward.
It receives the data.
It authenticates that the
data came from a Nest device,
that it's not someone
trying to spoof us.
And then it writes it
to a durable store.
From there, we move to
the processing layer.
The processing layer is
made up of Storm and Kafka.
On the Storm side
of things, we've
got one topology that is
responsible for each kind
of data that we process at Nest.
But no matter which
topology it is, no matter
which data source it is, that
topologies do the same thing.
They extract the data from
whatever format it's in.
They transform it
into avro, and then
they load that data into Kafka.
From there, we move
to the loading layer.
The loading data consists
of Cloud Dataflow.
And I want to highlight one
of the really nice features
of Cloud Dataflow, which
is, as Sam mentioned,
it can run in both batch
and streaming mode.
So this might sound
like a simple thing,
but it ends up making
our operational workflows
a lot easier.
We can use streaming
mode for streaming data
in real time for the normal
operation of the service.
But we can also use batch
mode by just changing
a few lines of
configuration to do
historical back loads or
particularly large load jobs.
So this simple feature ends
up saving us a ton of time.
From there, Dataflow writes
into our storage layer.
We primarily use BigQuery,
although as I mentioned before,
we also maintain a footprint
in Bigtable and HDFS.
And so up into this point,
what we've seen so far
constitutes our data platform.
Everything else that we're
going to talk about now
constitutes the
applications, or applications
that run on top of the platform.
We've got a number of
different applications.
We've got some monitoring
applications and reporting
applications that help us make
sure our devices are doing
what we think they
should be doing,
and also that are general
fleet health is strong.
We've got machine
learning algorithms
that come from
Kevin and his team
that we've scaled up
to run on production.
We've also got a number
of analytics applications
or various workflows from
our consumer analytics teams.
And finally, a
number of consumer
insights that we
take and transform
the data from the devices back
into value for our customers.
I'll talk about two my
favorite consumer insights
application later on
in the presentation.
So at this point, we're at a
point that I'm sure many of you
have been at before.
We've got all the data loaded.
We've got all the data stored.
Now what do we do with it?
So we had the same question.
We went out and talked to
all of our device teams--
the camera team, the
smoke detector team,
the thermostat team, all
of the algorithms teams
to see what they might
like to do with it,
all of the analytics
teams to see
how they might like to use it.
And no matter the team
that we talked to,
the results came back the same.
They wanted to be able to do
fleet level analysis quickly
and easily.
So to help them out, we
built our first prototype.
We built it using PySpark and
Zeppelin, two great open source
technologies out of Apache.
It looks something like this.
And I'd like to take a
minute to walk through it.
So this was HVAC runtime.
It's calculated with PySpark.
For those of you
who aren't familiar,
HVAC stands for heating,
ventilation, and air
conditioning.
So it's a measure of how
much time your furnace
or how much time your air
conditioner was running
throughout the course of a day.
You can see on the x-axis here,
we've got fraction of a day
with HVAC running.
This is a histogram.
On the y-axis, you've
got the fraction
of the device population.
So all the way on the
right, you see that about 5%
of the population was
running 100% of the day.
All the way on the left, you
see about 20% of the population
was running not at all
during the course of the day.
This might be alarming,
except that this data came
from a set of test devices.
So that leads into one
of the major complexities
that we found with this system.
It was really costly
to run analyzes
like this on all of production.
We had the capacity to
run it on production.
And for the most important
workflows we did.
But if you wanted to think
about other types of workflows,
it became really
tricky to do so.
One of the main reasons
this was so tricky
is that our storage was
coupled to our compute.
So unless we picked exactly
the right instance type
with exactly the
right amount of RAM,
exactly the right
amount of storage,
and exactly the
right number of CPUs,
we always had too much of one
and not enough of the other.
I was describing this
problem to my roommate
as I was preparing
this talk, and she
mentioned that she had the same
problem, except for she had it
when she went to the
store and she bought chips
and she bought salsa.
So no matter what, she
always said too much of one
and not enough for the other.
We've got the same
problem at Nest,
except for we've got it
with storage and compute.
Of course that leads to
frequent resource contention.
We had when cluster where
the data were located.
We ran both high
priority workflows on it,
but also lower priority
analytics tasks,
which meant that the
lower priority analytics
tasks were frequently preempted
or bumped from the workflows.
This meant that
our analytics team
had to either go back
and reschedule or rerun
those workflows, or have
gaps in their analysis.
That also meant that our team
took on the role of a part time
sysadmin.
We got many phone
calls saying, hey,
this workflow has
just been killed.
It's run out of memory.
Can you help us get
it running again,
which wasn't a great working
environment for the team.
There were a number of
operational complexities
that we ran into as well.
So PySpark and Zeppelin
were great tools,
but they weren't built to do
this sort of dashboarding.
So we ended up building
a separate service that
was responsible for generating
JSON blobs that represented
these templates that
we wanted to create,
loading them into the notebook
cache of the Zeppelin monitor,
restarting the service so the
Zeppelin monitor picked up
on the new notebooks.
This worked well for
one user, but you
can imagine as
multiple users started
trying to use this system
and it was frequently
restarting all the time, it
wasn't a great experience
for them.
Additionally there
was a constraint
that there was a maximum number
of notebooks that could be
loaded on the machine at once.
So we had to build a
second service that
was responsible for
backing these notebooks up
to durable store and
then pulling them back
in when we needed them.
It wasn't a great
experience for the people
who wanted to see the data.
This next point is an
especially important one.
I want to take a moment
to talk about it.
One of the things that we
care most about at Nest
is protecting our users'
data and protecting
our users' privacy.
And many of the mechanisms from
the systems that we were using
provided only clunky
authentication
and authorization, which
made it difficult to do
fast and flexible data
analysis to return value
to our customers.
A similar problem
was that it became
very difficult to build analyzes
back to different teams.
So for example, imagine that
the thermostat team came to us
and said, hey, we've got
this great new data type
that we want to store.
We know that your
cluster is full.
We know that we're going to
have to expand the cluster.
What's it going to take
to load that data type in?
It was difficult to figure
out exactly how much
that extra space would cost.
We had some heuristics to help
us come up with estimates.
They always proved to either
be too high or too low.
And so at the end we ended
up billing most of the cost
back to our team, which
was great from a billings
perspective or a
management perspective,
but terrible from a team
bottom line perspective.
And finally, if you were an
analytics team that had already
generated some data
that you wanted
to use to augment or
color your analysis,
it was difficult to get
data into the system.
You had to learn a
new set of tools.
You had to get the
appropriate permissions.
And then you had to figure
out how to join and link
those two together.
So I'd like to take
a little bit of time
to talk about the solution
that we came up with.
So on the left here,
this is a zoomed
in view of the architecture
that we discussed previously.
And it starts with the events
in Cloud BigQuery up at the top.
So those events
are the same events
that were loaded from Kafka
into BigQuery by Dataflow.
And once we've got the
data available in BigQuery,
we then built a processing
library on top of it.
The processing library
was responsible for two
different pieces.
One, there's a number
of Nest-specific nuances
in our data set.
So the processing library
was aware of those nuances
and provided a higher level
abstraction on top of them
to make it easier to work with.
And two, one of the
most frequent kinds
of analyzes that we do at
Nest is time series analysis.
So it provided a number of
very useful higher level
abstractions for
time series analysis.
One of the really nice
things, as Sam mentioned,
was that even though we're
running in Cloud Dataflow,
the code is just Apache Beam.
It's completely open
source, completely portable.
So if we wanted to, we could
pull this code out of Dataflow
and run it elsewhere, run
it on our own cluster,
run it wherever
we might want to.
We're not planning
on doing that.
We love working with Dataflow.
But it is really nice to have
the flexibility to do that.
Wherever we do the computation,
after it's complete,
we load the data back into
BigQuery for further processing
or analysis.
And from there there's a number
of really nice integrations
that make it easy to visualize.
Two of my favorites
are up on the screen.
You've got Data
Studio and Datalab.
But it's also got really easy
connectors for Excel or Tableau
or Google Sheets or
whatever you might want
to use to take a look at it.
So I'd like to talk
about two advantages,
or a couple of advantages
from using the system.
First and foremost
was autoscaling.
This autoscaling
was huge for us.
It made it really easy for
us to develop code locally,
to test code locally,
and then to push it out
to our production cluster
to run at scale by only
changing a few configs.
And to demonstrate
how powerful this was,
I'd like to tell a short story.
We had a camera systems engineer
who was a great engineer,
but again didn't have
too much familiarity
with building services
or analytics workflows.
He was able to get up and
running using the libraries
we created in only a day.
So there was a huge
operational advantage
from using this system.
Part of the reason
it was such a big win
was we were finally able to
decouple storage from compute.
So as I mentioned before,
all of this storage
was handled by BigQuery.
All of the compute was
handled by Dataflow.
So we can add new
logs to the system
without worrying about
scaling out Dataflow,
or we could add new
analysis pipelines
without worrying about
scaling out BigQuery.
And finally, because everything
runs as a managed service,
there was no more
resource contention
with production jobs, which
meant that the analytics
teams could run their
jobs without worrying
about backfill, and also
without worrying about missing
windows in their data sets,
and that our team got many
fewer late night phone calls.
There are a number of
operational advantages as well.
This first one is a big one.
They've got this really
nicely defined access control
model that made it really easy
for us to grant people access
to the right data at
the right time and only
when they need it.
So their access control
model was great and increased
our operating security.
A similar system, we're finally
able to build analyzes by team.
So whenever you
kick off a workflow,
you're able to set a billing
config or billing ID.
That means that the teams
that kick off workflows
are billed for only the
compute cycles they use
and nothing more.
And finally as we
mentioned previously,
really great options
for data visualization.
Data Studio, Datalab,
Tableau, anything
that you want to work
with is available.
So I'd like to revisit one
of the example use cases
that we talked about before.
This is the same HVAC runtime
analysis, except for this time
it's computed with
Cloud Dataflow.
So on the x-axis you
see the day that it ran.
On the y-axis you see
the fraction of time
that your furnace or
air conditioner was on.
It starts out low in October
while things are still
pretty warm.
It increases through
January 10th where there was
a huge storm in the Northeast.
And then it falls
back off as things
start to warm up in the spring.
This is a really
simple computation.
But this graph hides a
really important fact.
This is one of the
first times that we
were able to run an analysis
like this on all of production.
So all of those sampling
pieces that I talked before,
where you're worried
about getting
the wrong population or
missing population or masking
populations, we don't
have to worry about.
This is great if you want to
build more complicated or more
nuanced machine learning
models on top of the data.
You can be sure that you're
hitting all of the points.
So with that, I
want to highlight
that even a simple computation
like the one that I just
mentioned, even just figuring
out HVAC on and off periods
can have some really
positive returns and value
for our customers.
This is one of my favorite
products that we offer at Nest.
This is the monthly
energy report.
So every month we
email our Nest users
and say how much energy you
used as compared to last month.
We try to sprinkle a little
machine learning on top of it
to say why your
energy usage changed.
Maybe it got colder.
Maybe the weather changed.
Maybe you adjusted
your thermostat
to be more comfortable
in your home.
We also provide one of my
favorite statistics at Nest.
So every month we give a summary
of how much energy people have
saved by installing Nest
across the entire population.
This is the one from January.
So this is current
through January 31.
Since October 11th--
I'm sorry, October
2011, Nesters have
saved 11.3 billion kilowatt
hours, which is enough energy
to freeze all of the ice
necessary for 2 million ice
skating rinks.
So that's a pretty
cool insight that
comes out of a relatively
straightforward data analysis
once you're able to perform
it on the entire fleet.
It's also a lot of
energy to save simply
by installing a thermostat.
Fast and flexible
data analysis also
lets us prove how
efficient our devices are.
So we're really
proud to announce
that Nest was the first
thermostat in America
with an Energy
Star certification.
And some of the fast and
flexible data analysis
techniques that I
talked about helped
us be able to prove
this efficiency out.
So with that, I'd
like to wrap up.
Using the technologies
available to us within GCP
provided an easy
path from development
to production, paved by
shared and scalable tooling
throughout.
So that means that an
algorithms engineer like Kevin
can develop and prototype data
sets using one set of tools,
and then take those same tools
to do analysis when he deploys
the algorithm to production.
There's no need to learn another
toolset for doing data at scale
or for doing smaller
data analysis locally.
The access control models they
provide give the right people
the right access to the
right data at the right time.
And similarly, the billing
operations that they allow for
allows you to build the right
teams for what they use,
and more importantly,
for only what they use.
But most importantly,
the data availability
and access controls
provided by GCP
help us further our mission of
creating the home that cares.
So with that, I'd
like to thank you
to all of the team
members at Nest and Google
who contributed
to these projects.
These weren't built
by a single person.
We have a great engineering
team at Nest, seven of whom
are here today that are
wonderful to work with.
We've got a great
engineering team at Google,
including people like
Sam, who have helped us
along the process.
So thank you to both.
And I'd also like to thank you
in the audience for staying
and listening.
We'll be outside after the talk.
Feel free to come up, ask any
questions that you might have,
say hello.
And like I mentioned, we've also
got some other data services
engineers from Nest who
can help to field questions
or provide more information.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]